[Music]
packed full of sumptuous homely dishes
today's all about comfort food i think
every home cook needs recipes that don't
just taste delicious but satisfy the
soul too the type of food that wraps its
arms around you and gives you big hugs
so when you want to give your family and
friends a big serving of love here's my
ultimate comfort food
dish is guaranteed to make you feel cozy
even on the coldest of days
first up a breakfast that will bring you
a warm glow in the morning my spiced
baked porridge
perfect for a big comfort family
breakfast
for lunch i'm pulling out all the stops
with a fantastic twist on one of
britain's favorite comfort dishes ginger
beer battered fish with chilli minted
mushy peas
if you're gonna do it
do it properly
for dinner my youngest daughter tilly is
in the kitchen and we share the secret
ingredient in every comfort food dish
happy memories
did you like to help me make your hot
pot when she made them for you
always such as hot pot with beetroot and
potato gratins on the menu for dessert
spiced apple compote
silly we're on for a treat this is my
ultimate comfort food breakfast
lunch and dinner
first up it's breakfast my spiced baked
porridge
absolutely love it why
i grew up with it there's something very
scottish about porridge
it's that kind of sort of great start to
the day
my father used to say
porridge needs salt
and salt only
it separates the men from the boys
didn't really like it who was insistent
salt puts hairs on you
i used to sneak a couple of sugar lumps
from cafes and put them
in my porridge without him watching
these days my porridge has much more
flavor than just salt it's packed with
fruit nuts and spices add vanilla seeds
to porridge oats or oatmeal
really important just to rub the vanilla
through
the oatmeal makes it nice and fragrant
now a little teaspoon
of cinnamon makes it spicier and then
nutmeg
[Music]
already
that
smells incredible i quite like making
this up week at a time and
jack absolutely loves it now
whole almonds
now if you don't like that kind of
crunch running through the porridge you
can chop these up or blend them to a
powder but i quite like the sort of
texture hazelnut nuts incredibly good
a really nice crunch keep your vanilla
pod in there as well that just gives it
even more lift and of course once it's
baked just pull it out instead of sugar
i'm adding sweetness with fruit fresh
pears and raisins
cranberries are great as well chopped
apricots as well dried apricots in there
dried mango i love dried fruit
next pour in a pint of milk and mix
this can be done the night before left
in the fridge
and then
a couple minutes before you go to bake
it add your cream
now
into your dish
it looks quite liquid
but by the time it bakes
has this really nice rich crust on top
and then
just a nice little nutmeg
on top
now bake at 180 for 30 to 35 minutes
then take the porridge out sprinkle on
demerara sugar and grill to create a
sweet golden crust
and sort of glaze on top
beautiful
literally
for three to four minutes
look at that
that makes me feel proud to be scottish
because it's perfect for a big comfort
family breakfast it's rich it's
sumptuous
and it's just a humble oatmeal
phenomenal especially in the winter my
spice baked porridge with all those nuts
and fruit it's a bowl full of love to
start the day
[Music]
next i'm showing you how to cook the
comfort food i crave
but first here's a closer look at some
of the key ingredients you'll need to
make them
[Music]
my ultimate comfort food has to be
sausage i grew up on the classic british
banger made with ground pour salt pepper
spices and breadcrumbs and i'm using
these ones for dinner
the general rule with sausage the higher
the meat content the better they'll
taste
[Music]
for my ultimate lunch i'm frying fish so
you'll need an oil you can get to a high
temperature here are the different oils
you can use
groundnut oil it's made from peanuts and
it's used a lot in southeast asian
cooking
rapeseed made from those yellow
flowering crops this has the lowest
saturated fat content of any oil and has
a lovely delicate flavor
sunflower oil made from sunflower seeds
is mildly nutty
a good cheap all-rounder with a neutral
flavor is vegetable oil which is the
blend of oils like corn soybean and
sunflower
apples were my favorite fruit growing up
originally came from china but today in
britain we grow over 2 000 different
types
[Music]
the most popular eating apples in the uk
are braven and gala but don't miss out
on some of the older types like the
sweet nutty russets and fragrant coxes
when it comes to cooking apples it's got
to be a sharp brambly which i'm using as
part of my compot for lunch
you know that feeling when you really
want a particular dish and nothing else
will do that's comfort food ultimate
comforting lunch has to be fished with
peas i've loved it ever since i was a
kid and to make it even more delicious
i've given it a few modern tweaks for my
ultimate fish i'm doing the best
crunchiest lightest batter imaginable
with a hint of ginger
to go with it chili minted mushy peas
[Music]
in order to make sure that the batter
stays nice and crispy and the fish stays
nice and firm
the secret is to season the fish salt
and pepper that will draw out the
moisture and that will keep the fish
really nice and firm
put it in the fridge for around 10
minutes to let the seasoning work its
magic now the batter as always
when making any batter always sieve the
flour i want a bit of heat in the batter
so
a nice teaspoon of cayenne pepper
season the flour salt and pepper
and then
two teaspoons of baking powder
this almost lightens the load with the
batter now ginger beer
it gives that batter this sort of unique
spicy individual flavor it's delicious
with a fish and a nice tablespoon
of oil
just basic vegetable oil gives it a nice
sheen
give that a good mix
you really want it almost like the
consistency of
double cream
too thin and the batter runs off
especially when it hits the fryer too
thick and it actually prevents the fish
from getting cooked so you've got to get
it to that just that sort of double
cream texture let it rest for as long as
possible to give you an even textured
batter
now the season should have worked its
magic and drawn out the excess moisture
from the fish so it's on to the next
stage
fish
has gone slightly firmer
perfect for frying
start by coating the fish in flour
seasoned with pepper
pat that nice and dry into your hands so
you haven't got any excess flour the
flour stops the batter from running off
the fish i'm just gonna check to see if
my oil's ready by putting a little touch
of batter
into the fryer
you see it bubbling straight to the very
top
that tells you that the oil is ready
never really ever
fill the pan
above halfway
if the oil starts to get too hot
first thing you do turn off the gas
second thing add some oil into it to
cool it down
hold the fish by the corner
unless you put it in
and roll it round
then gently slap the fish on the sides
of the bowl to get rid of excess batter
now
in
and lay away
and just gently drop it in
twist
your pan
that stops it from sticking
at the bottom
oil should be gently sort of bubbling
away
but notice as we're frying the fish
there's no spitting of any water from
the fish fry the fish for three to five
minutes gently turning halfway through
once the bat is golden and crisp it's
ready
look they look stunning it's like these
big crispy pillows of
beautifully textured cart
leave the fish to rest on a kitchen
towel to blot excess oil
meanwhile it's quick and easy chilly
minted mushy peas
now how much you peas a little teaspoon
of olive oil
and a nice
knob of butter
into the pan
shallot
finely chopped that adds a bit of
sweetness to the peas slots into the pan
chili
these are delicious when you eat peas
and they're slightly spicy
they're even better
garlic
in the peas sweat off the chili the
garlic and the shallots
before the peas join those spices simply
blanch in salted boiling water infuse
with their perfect partner
fresh mint stalks and all
and then put your frozen peas in now
what's the peas i've got nice and soft
drain them now take off the stalks and
then add your peas to the shallots
i love that sound
mix all that chili and garlic
in there
a little seasoning
finishing the frozen peas off like this
absolutely delicious
onto your board
crush
now
you cannot beat
crushed
delicious peas
those peas is incredible
top with chopped mint
chilli minted mushy peas so simple and
perfect with easy ginger beer battered
fish
a nice spicy crispy batter and that just
reaffirms
the importance of comfort food if you're
gonna do it
do it properly
oh
my spicy twist is proof you can update a
comforting classic
and the best way to eat this is with
crispy buttered sauteed potatoes cooked
with garlic rosemary and thyme
to take this happy food to a whole new
level
[Music]
no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells filled in the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
i love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and i hope
it will always remind my kids of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood is my
youngest daughter tilly
my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah
what do you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with the baked beans sometimes with
baked beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
daddy
[Music]
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be good now
sausages
are getting lots of color because this
is going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nunnies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and take them out
to rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little
buds that will get the onions
packed with flavour
that's kind of nice nice mushrooms in
give them a nice little stir
did you like to help them make your hot
pot when she made them for you i used to
always help them make the hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
her onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar is giving that nice sort of
gloss when i put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine end
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look pretty good
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't boil in the oven
170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes
and pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called brae burns what other apples do
you know green ones what they called um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandmas no
red no
pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're going to do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the bramley cooking apple with the
sweetness of the braeburn get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger
and three little cinnamon sticks i want
you to remember that because we're gonna
look for them
okay because once we've used them and
they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving
definitely now we just let that go a
little bit darker
okay
and then
the place is quick doesn't it
give that
a nice
little
toss
okay nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
and we go into there what's that coming
out dad so that is a little bit of the
puree i'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with the cinnamon
we've got the ginger gingers
it smells so nice how nice is that look
see the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in they're
great separate
off
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
now let's see if you've got a really
nice stiff peak so you lift them up
now that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice that by hand
we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butter scotch
now to make the cream even lighter fold
in those whisked egg whites and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with the flat leaf parsley
wow look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel-good factor
mommy jack holly megan
this isn't it
[Music]
it smells amazing
tasty delicious one of my favorite it's
so tasty i love it it's so good i love
the mushrooms as well that is so nice
and so simple when i was your age guys
nanny was making this for me in those
days the sausages weren't as fat as days
you would ride to school on dinosaurs
excuse me i'm not out
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
okay today it's all about healthy food i
love running marathons and playing sport
so this subject's very close to my heart
healthy food has a bit of a bad
reputation for being slightly boring and
bland but it doesn't have to be and
that's one of the keys to maintaining a
good diet you need to make food that's a
pleasure to eat as well as being healthy
packed with flavor here's more of my
ultimate healthy food
for breakfast my secret to amazing
healthy granola made in minutes and full
of goodness
next a quick and easy healthy lunch
bursting with flavor and brimming with
lean protein steamed mussels with cherry
tomatoes and saffron crisp breads
for dinner incredible spicy lamb chops
with superfoods broccoli and burger
wheat and a vitamin pack healthy mango
sundae
proof that food that is good for you can
taste great
these are more of my ultimate healthy
recipes breakfast lunch and dinner
first up my homemade granola for
breakfast
every time i put
a healthy recipe together a healthy dish
it needs a bit of a treat so this is a
lovely stunning
get up and go fresh granola first thing
in the morning the treat here
is in that little baby
honey
so that sweetens it
so just start off with 200 ml
of delicious honey
into a pan just to warm up in she goes
now
i know these are a chef's favorite but
it makes all the difference especially
for breakfast a fresh
vanilla pod and i think of the way that
i use herbs to add
flavour to soups and salads
i'd like to think the vanilla does
exactly the same
scrape out all those wonderful seeds in
now
the staple of the granola
is the oats
next
puff rice delicious
crunchy
but light
and fluffy next add wheat bran and your
seeds pumpkin sunflower and linseed
and then almonds
incredible
that nice heavy weight
from the nut bunch
now bring the honey to the boil
slowly drizzle that amazing honey
in
give that a really good mix
coat the granola with the hot honey just
slowly churn it
using the outside of the bowl
you can see it just getting nice and
sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey it's ready to bake
now spread the mix on baking paper i'm
gonna season it lightly with a touch of
salt on top
the salt throughout
dries up the oats and the honey will
roast
color and glaze
the granola
nice into the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
10 minutes into the cooking simply run a
spoon across the top to turn the mix and
ensure it's crunchy all over
smell that light
roast
look at the color
honestly look it's crispy
it's delicious
now i'm gonna tart it up and put some
lovely dried cranberries
that just gives us chewy
sweet flavor delicious
and then finally these beautiful berries
goji berries goji berries are high in
antioxidants and have been eating china
for centuries for their healing
properties but you can add any dried
fruit you like the cranberries and the
goji berries gives it that nice chewy
rich texture
to the granola
now this is the best way
to store it it looks incredible
really incredible
look at that
now
eat well stay well
right
milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good and it's packed with
healthy grains superfood berries and
seeds it's incredibly good for you too a
breakfast for champions
next i'll be showing you a fantastic
healthy lunch and dinner
there are no magic ingredients just
great fresh food here's a closer look at
what you'll need to make them
first up for lunch one of my favorite
ingredients mussels they're great value
an excellent source of nutrients and
lean protein and they are so versatile
you can poach them grill them or bake
them but i'm going to steam them with
cherry tomatoes
pancetta sherry and chili for lunch
[Music]
my next healthy ingredient is bulgur
wheat richer in protein fiber and
minerals than many other grains the
nutty flavored bulgur wheat is made by
par boiling drying then grinding whole
wheat it's fantastic in puddings in
stuffings or in salads like the charred
broccoli one i'll be serving for dinner
[Music]
finally not strictly an ingredient but
it certainly adds flavor the griddle pan
perfect for grilling almost anything
with minimum oil and maximum taste plus
excess fat just drains away you can find
them for as little as 10 pounds trust me
it's worth the investment and takes veg
meat and fish to another healthy level
are renowned for working all hours and
having unhealthy lifestyles but i try to
keep myself fit and eat healthily and
it's not as difficult as you might think
so however busy your life is i'm gonna
prove to you you don't need to always go
for fast food or ready meals it's easy
to cook fantastic healthy meals at home
here's my ultimate healthy lunch fast to
cook but crammed with flavor a delicious
saffron flatbread with mussels it
doesn't get any healthy than that first
job the super easy saffron flatbread
[Music]
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the colour
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
rich your saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
then simply need to bring the dough
together mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now
sit that in your bowl cover it with clim
film let it rest for 10 to 15 minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'm gonna cut that into
three and then roll them nice and thinly
now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
to like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little
salt cooking the flatbread is easy just
pop in a hot dry pan and they're ready
in minutes as it hits the pan it starts
the blister
she's ready
for turning
beautiful get that color on there now
you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
on to the muscles now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta i want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavor
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes they're just going in
whole
the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
takes moments once it's brown and crisp
put your garlic chili and whole cherry
tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry i think it
works better in this recipe than white
wine which is classically used at this
stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavor
got to lock in
that heat the muscles will take four to
five minutes to steam in the meantime
cut your flatbreads into strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
health eating is all about balance fresh
home-cooked food in sensible portions
with a few treats now and again my
ultimate healthy dinner is a great
balance of protein carbs vegetables and
fruit but doesn't compromise on taste or
flavor
the key to healthy eating is to have a
host of wholesome recipes up your sleeve
so you're never short of inspiration
joining me to create this healthy dinner
is jack's twin sister holly
we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
char grill broccoli and bulgur wheat
salad for dessert it's healthy mango
sundae
holly
[Music]
then i can help daddy with the dessert
yes please and the lamb cutlets
now
we all know that you love desserts yeah
yeah we'll do a little
yogurt parfait with some macerated
fruits
so the first thing i'd like you to do is
take a tablespoon
of icing sugar dust that over the fruits
good
now sad enough that's perfect danny
thank you
zest the orange over the fruits and
what's going to happen now it's going to
start to sort of marinate i'm going to
put some basil in there
that'll make it really flavoursome
fresh puzzle in
and then i'm going to give that a little
mix up
i'm going to squeeze
some fresh orange juice in there
nice and gently
okay
how gorgeous do those berries look now
okay
so we just leave them just marinate okay
and that's what we call
macerated berries
now for the mango sundae
right mangoes and please
i love mangoes
nice
now they're naturally sweet okay
on
oh
that smells incredible
now
how fresh
does that smell very now you love art
right yeah i do so you're gonna put
these together so a nice little dollop
of mango at the bottom nice and slowly
once each glass has a layer of mango
puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yoghurt and alternate until the glass is
full
well done now they're yummy from there
you get your berries
you sit your berries on top
they taste so fresh
but now they've been marinated and the
berries have been slightly macerated and
then finally look
get your icing sugar and just tap
on top
they
look it's beautiful
now they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay
so
if i take three
and promise not to sneeze
and you take one open the fridge door
good job
dessert's chilling in the fridge now for
the super simple main course to go with
the aromatic lamb chops a tasty char
grill broccoli and burger wheat salad
to cook the bulgur wheat just simmer
until tender then drain
to give the broccoli a char grilled
flavor simply cook with salt in a hot
dry pan until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mix together harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and burger wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salad is done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes
a lot a lot on a scale of one to ten
ten okay these lamb chops are gonna be
delicious
first i'm gonna marinate them i'll start
putting the spices in yeah first one
coriander good so a teaspoon of
coriander seeds in a little touch of
what's that human cumin well done cumin
in
one of daddy's favorites
turmeric chew me a teaspoon of that in
there
now
a little touch
of salt
and then i want you to start grinding
that down while i get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix please for
daddy
that looks amazing after that get the
garlic lay it flat
and look
it almost purees the garlic so we get a
nice paste
see underneath sorry about dirting your
nails
it's okay i just smell like garlic now
nothing wrong with that
the more you smell of garlic
the less the boys are gonna date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of
spicy
and fruity now get the ginger and do
exactly the same with the ginger when
you grate it like this it turns into the
most amazing
ginger puree i forgot
come on holly put some muscle into it
good girl
nice see all that there you got the back
of the knife
now i'm gonna drizzle some olive oil in
there okay and you bring that together
as a paste for daddy there you go
stuck on no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now
that smells incredible that
is a delicious paste
so i'm gonna tip
all that marinade on
to the lamb
and then i want you to rub it all in to
those lamb chops
then we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look you get them in there and you
rub
all that marinade
the flavor inside these chops come on
holly come on
your jumper's fine
just
smell that
nice fresh
and the earlier you do this the better
the turmeric is starting to stain
the lamb chops they're not even cooked
yet yet they smell delicious yeah
what do you like honestly oh my nails
oh my nails
delicious after marinating from 10
minutes to overnight but if you can't
wait to get your hands on them you can
grill the chops straight away gas nice
and high and grilling them
it's going to make them slightly
healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you sit more in the
pan that's right what i want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
[Music]
see
go
on we're going to cook them
three sides
one side up flip it and then on the back
see this bit here yeah i'm gonna grill
it on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please daddy
nice
some fresh mint
i want you to pick
the mint
please and give it a little chop and mix
it in with a yogurt smells amazing
doesn't it
so yogurt
in
chop up
the mint please
have a look
at the color
of the lamb
[Music]
how nice
are they
they smell incredible
grilling them this way they cook so much
quicker
okay it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful excited yes barry
good eric and megan will like those i
hope so
[Music]
see what i'm doing i'm standing the
chopped up yeah yeah we're not going to
dry out this way
is that chopped enough try a bit more
that's fine and then mix it
into the yogurt please darling this
isn't too hard is it dad not a salmon
how would you know when they're done
nice and pink three and a half to four
minutes each side
medium
six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your landmine darling
medium rare that's what i always go for
a lamb cutlet at its best
will be medium red off with the gas
okay
it's got a lovely
lovely flavor
okay
look at that
wow
i'm in heaven
i'll carry the lamb
and the yogurt if you get the bowl of
wheat and the broccoli they're done that
smells incredible it really does
fast and easy to make packed with
goodness and utterly delicious with a
bit of kitchen know-how you have my
ultimate healthy dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes
[Music]
the perfect meal for any busy family so
excited i could smell it from a mile
away oh really should i go get this
stuff
why not oh can we start serving she's
dying to show her desserts they are tell
oh yes please
oh wow that's very fancy look how proud
she is they look neat gorgeous
all right holes they look amazing they
do beautiful oh look at the colors it's
kind of luminous
but after you've eaten all your broccoli
that's a long time away nice and healthy
and she got her hands dirty for the
first time in 13 years
it's delicious really really lovely
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck